now you you've been in so many films
very experienced for the camera but in
in real life didn't you pretend to be
your own agent I did I've never been
very good with being agented or with
with agents and I have far them left
right in the center I fired one poor man
who was a brilliant agent just because I
saw his anus we were at some film
festival in his shower broke down he
wanted to borrow my bath in my suite and
I said alright and I forgot he was in
there and I walked in and he was on all
fours washing who washes like that such
a thing and anyway the view was awful
yes and his bottom towards me this awful
sopia
flag of Japan
you're a great agent I'm a really very
fond of you but I've seen your anus and
you gotta go I yeah I did then invent an
agent for three or four years I called
James Howie Lee which was very saved a
lot of money you know people would send
any of messantia script and James Howard
Lee would say thank you so much for
submitting the script I'll get it to
Hugh as soon as possible and get back to
you but I got caught out in the end
because I used to you know do these
emails a bit drunk and I you know to say
he was read the script and he really
enjoys it like to meet meet up best
wishes Hugh and then they rang one time
and I you know I haven't got a voice for
James how are you for some reason I
panicked tonight and I went with genteel
Edinborough old lady pretty much Janet
from dr. Finn
[Laughter]
[Music]